you're here right now because you've
seen a clip of me uh-oh
she's still using that tone dude yeah
yep
I'm so don't tell me what I feel I'm so
angry and you're justified in your anger
Oh what I said was tone deaf insensitive
and stupid she should be a politician
bro yes seriously a calculated apology
I'm watching the scene from house of
cards holding your hands Chad is so good
we are not angry
hey stocks stocks mods hold the line we
can't wait to hear this lame apology I
love them people apologizing you there's
just zero remorse you can see right yeah
their brain they're like I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I'm doing this
because they want to hear it okay let's
let it rip and I recognize that I
recognize that there's no context that I
can give that would excuse what I said
so I won't
I can only own what I said and I will
the clip that you saw does not represent
my true feelings i've streamed for
hundreds of hours and i've said
support communities after you support
yourself first subscribe if you have the
disposable income to do so support
communities before you support yourself
what the [ __ ] ya don't ya are you
talking about yeah okay maybe's trying
to say is give before you take in a
weird way I don't know what she means by
communities maybe the twitch community
yeah I don't know pay my bills before
you pay yours I expressed opinions that
I do not hold at all what said things
that I don't mean and they were vile
alright I don't have a problem of it
being written it's just the delivery
just makes it feel like it's not real it
would just be way better if she came out
and said look I wash that back and I
realize I'm an [ __ ]
and that's it and exactly and I know
become a better person and this is like
this is a character art for me and I'm
sorry for being a dick and I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna really think about what I
said and wrote it's just like I'm gonna
try to be better going forward when
people speak in absolutes like oh I've
I'm sorry I I I take everything back
it's like that doesn't show sympathy or
thought at all
well you didn't say that she said I
expressed opinions that I don't hold
that's okay you can't say what do you
what are you what are you saying you're
schizophrenic or you clearly held this
opinion you held it enough to go on a
streaming and berate people with it and
now you're saying oh actually that's not
my opinion yeah I didn't I said it but
it was vile and I don't actually believe
it yeah that's what that's what I mean
like when when people just do hard 180s
it's not genuine at all you know it's
like you have to I don't get why it's so
hard I mean you know maybe it's that
what you were just saying it's when
people don't have remorse
so I don't understand why apologies are
so hard look at these scope of apologies
from whoever creators and what-have-you
know how many more go [ __ ] viral for
sucking versus the ones that are decent
its yeah oh who's that girl on YouTube
who got caught like fake crying and it
was it was some [ __ ] from a while back I
don't know there's a there's a ton of I
I was just watching PewDiePie's video
like reacting to youtuber apology videos
or something like that
yeah that's pretty funny yeah I don't
know man it's just I don't want to like
be one of these people that piles it on
and just like jumping at or just cuz
whatever you know that that's why I'm
bringing this up that full scope but now
that we've seen the before and after I
don't know man
personally I feel like she's got some
work to do but I'm not gonna judge I'm
just gonna judge her stage I just dude
she sucks I mean yeah no you're right
you're right no there's no point in
[ __ ] hiding it
yeah the opinion sucks it really does
yeah but it's not hers though yeah it's
not her she doesn't know yeah I like you
baby bro she could have even kept that
statement and just said I don't hold
that opinion anymore you know what I
mean it's like one [ __ ] word to make
it seem a little bit more real but it
doesn't even have that hold on I gotta
just get some let's get some quotes from
the chat real quick because that's
always the best part oh [ __ ] off it uh
starting soon Oh
she's trying really hard to be sad right
now yeah I'm not gonna play the audio
anyway we've been on this for a minute
yeah that's your drama for the link
you